♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SO, GAVIN NEWSOM IS
THE GOVERNOR OF OUR LARGEST
STATE CALIFORNIA.
HE IS A LIBERAL DEMOCRAT.
THE BUT THE PROBLEM IS DEEPER
THAN THAT.
HE IS JUST A BAD GOVERNOR.
THE STATE DOESN'T WORK VERY
WELL.
IT'S MORE CROWDED EVERY YEAR.
IT'S DIRTY AS HELL.
YOU'VE GOT JUNKIES LIVING ON
EVERY STREET IN HONOR OF EVERY
PARK AND THEY CAN'T EVEN PUT THE
POWER ON.
IT'S A FAILED STATE.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
EVEN IF YOU DON'T LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA, YOU SHOULD BE
EMBARRASSED BY IT.
WHY DO WE ALLOW THIS AND WHY DO
WE LET SOME TINY BRAINED LIKE
AVENUES AND WRECK OUR PREVIOUS
STATE?
THAT'S HOW MOST PEOPLE FEEL,
EVEN DEMOCRATS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE JOINED THE RACE
AND LAST WEEK, ONE OF OUR
FRIENDS DID.
LARRY ELDER, WHO IS A RADIO SHOW
HOST JOINED IN THE RECALL EFFORT
IN THE ELECTION TO REPLACE HIM.
BUT NOW THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS TRYING TO KEEP LARRY ELDER
OFF THE BALLOT.
SO TODAY, HE ANNOUNCED THAT HE
IS SUING CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF
STATE, SURELY WEBER FOR
WRONGFULLY BLOCKING HIM FROM THE
BALLOT.
TALK ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
HE SAYS HE HAS COMPLIED WITH
STATE LAWS.
LARRY ELDER JOINS US.
SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR RUN.
UNLIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO RUN
FOR OFFICE, YOU HAVE BEEN VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT YOU BELIEVE.
IT'S ALL ON THE RECORD.
NO ONE NEEDS TO GUESS ABOUT WHAT
YOU WOULD DO BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT
DECADES OF SAYING IT ALOUD.
TELL US WHY THEY ARE TRYING TO
KEEP YOU OFF THE BALLOT.
>> WELL, TUCKER, WE HAVE GONE TO
COURT.
WE FILED A LAWSUIT LAST NIGHT.
WE ARE PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE A
HEARING TOMORROW.
NOT ONLY ME.
THERE IS ALSO A WOMAN WHO WAS
THE FIRST CHINESE
SHE SAID THAT SHE IS DOING IT
FOR OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW
BEING DEPRIVED OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE FOR LARRY
ELDER BECAUSE THE SECRETARY OF
STATE HAS DENIED ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ON THE BALLOT.
WHAT THEY ARE ARGUING IS THAT
TAX RETURNS, I DID REACT
SOMETHING THAT SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN REDACTED OR REDACTED
BEEN REACTED.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT IS.
SHE ELECTED NOT TO DO IT.
AND THAT IS WHY I BELIEVE THAT I
WAS TARGETED.
NOW A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ASKED
ME, TUCKER, WAS THIS RACISM?
NOW YOU KNOW ME FOR A LONG TIME.
I DON'T PLAY THAT.
WHAT I SAY IS IT'S NOT RACISM.
IT'S SAFISM.
IT'S LARRY.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW I'M THE GUY
THEY CAN TAKE THIS GUY DOWN.
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE FOR SOME 30 YEARS.
I'M ON EVERY MAJOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE HIGHER NAME RECOGNITION
THAN ANY OTHER CANDIDATE OTHER
THAN CAITLYN JENNER.
PEOPLE KNOW ME.
I'M FROM THE HOOD.
I'M FROM THE INNER CITY.
I CAN TALK FIRSTHAND ABOUT THE
DECLINING QUALITY OF SCHOOLS.
I CAN TALK FIRSTHAND ABOUT WHY
WE HAVE CRIME, WHILE WE HAVE
RISING HOMELESSNESS.
WHILE THE COST OF LIVING HAS
GOTTEN SO OUTRAGEOUS.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY, PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING CALIFORNIA AND GOING TO
PLACES LIKE TEXAS AND TENNESSEE
AND FLORIDA.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS.
IT HAS BEEN AROUND FOR 17 YEARS,
TUCKER.
AND FOR 17 YEARS, CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN DETERMINED TO BE THE WORST
STATE OF ALL 50 STATES.
AND I CAN TURN THAT AROUND.
AND THEY ARE SCARED TO DEATH.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, IF PEOPLE
ARE MOVING FROM SAN FRANCISCO,
WHICH HAS GOT TO BE THE
PRETTIEST CITY WE HAVE IN THIS
ENTIRE COUNTRY AND MOVING TO
RENO, WHICH NO OFFENSE, IS NOT.
AND IF A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE DOING
THAT, HE REALLY TELLS YOU THAT
IT'S LIKE SO MISMANAGED THAT YOU
ARE SEEING AN EXODUS OF NORMAL
PEOPLE.
CAN YOU WIN THE BATTLE TO BE ON
THE BALLOT?
I MEAN, THEY SAY THEY CARE ABOUT
DEMOCRACY, BUT THEY ARE TRYING
TO KEEP YOU OFF THE BALLOT?
HOW DOES THAT WORK EVEN?
>> I'M GOING TO BE ON THE
BALLOT.
WE ARE GOING TO FILE A LAWSUIT.
WE WILL TAKE IT UP TO THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
THIS LAW WAS DESIGNED TO MAKE
DONALD TRUMP TURN OVER FIVE
YEARS OF TAX RETURNS IN ORDER TO
BE ELIGIBLE TO RUN IN 2020.
IT WAS LITIGATED ALL THE WAY UP
TO THE LEFT WING SKIP CALIFORNIA
FROM COURT.
THE LAW WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
BUT THEY DID SAY IT WAS OKAY.
IT'S NOT EVEN CLEAR AND APPLIES
TO A RECALL ELECTION HERE THAT'S
WHY I'M TELLING PEOPLE TO GO TO
ELECT ELDER.COM.
HE HAS UNLIMITED ABILITY TO
RAISE MONEY AND SPEND MONEY.
REGARDING PUBLIC EDUCATION,
THERE ARE 300,000 PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
TUCKER.
I'M TOLD BY EXPERT AFTER EXPERT,
AT LEAST 5% ARE INCOMPETENT.
THAT'S 15,000 TEACHERS THAT ARE
IN THE HALLS OF OUR SCHOOLS MISS
EDUCATING OUR KIDS.
I WANT CHOICE IN SCHOOLS, AS DO
URBAN PARENTS, BLACK AND BROWN.
I'M GOING TO TURN THAT AROUND.
AND THERE'S ONLY ABOUT 75% OF
BLACK KIDS IN CALIFORNIA, TUCKER
WHO CANNOT READ AT --
THE ONE WHO WAS FEATURED OF THEM
WILL BE BOYS IN THE HOOD.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Tucker: YEAH, AND THEY ARE
THE ONES LECTURING.
TAX RETURNS TO RUN FOR OFFICE?
WHY NOT A LITERALLY TEST?
WHAT THE H  WHY THAT'S HARD
TO BELIEVE IT'S EVEN REAL.
AND I HOPE YOU BEAT IT, THAT YOU
IT.
LARRY ELDER, THANK YOU.
WE WILL BE FOL